should be live here. Hello.
Let me switch my screen over in a
second.
I just have to set the title first or
the uh the Twitch category.
Okay. Hello, Jess.
Fix this. Uh,
oops.
Where's the title thing?
We'll just do
Okay. Um,
let me explain where we're at.
We have puffer under 10k lines.
That result is like correct, good,
everything works. Nothing's broken. Over
the weekend, I uh kind of just gave
Codeex a thing and it came up with what
looked like a really good result, but
then after going through the math for
like well over 2 hours,
it completely cheated.
So, the models are still [ __ ] dumb.
They're just a lot better at hiding it,
which is kind of depressing, honestly.
Um
um I I I don't want the models to just
be bad and us to like just kind of be
screwed and have all progress be slow,
but it seems that that's kind of where
we are at the moment is these things are
very good at lying and um not that good
at much else.
So
here's what we're going to do. Um I'm
waiting for this stupid thing here. I'm
not going to just sit here waiting all
day. I was working. No algo improvement.
Um, it's still in the works, Jess.
There's still probably like I think we
can still get it to work cleanly. The
approach had some substantial hacks in
it, though. I'll explain what it is once
I have any idea of whether or not this
thing actually works. In the meantime, I
started working on this silly little
thing. This was just sort of like me
writing up my refactoring process into
something that I think would be useful
for contributors
uh who want to get better at writing
nicer code, but then also the lazy
people who want to just stick it into an
LLM. At least they will submit stuff
that does not make my eyes bleed.
So, we will try that. I was just
finishing writing this. I figured that
we'll do this. We'll see if um Codex has
anything else and if not we'll just kind
of like move on and maybe I'll help Finn
with net hack. Maybe I'll try uh some
selfplay stuff. We will see.
I'm just trying to think how I want to
introduce this and how short I want to
keep this as all.
And how much of this needs to be in this
file?
You're not
You are not using have
what?
You are not using have five.
I I don't know what that is.
Well, it's a little weird just because I
think I'm going to put like a blog post
together with this thing. Um,
is there a pro mode now?
I think
I don't know what the difference is with
those other than they're slower and
consume tokens.
Yeah.
I mean, this is already unbearably slow
to the point that if I were just
watching this in a loop, I'd just be
like,
"No, I need a new job." Like, this this
is just a side project thing.
more. I mean, these things currently are
just lighting money on fire. So, we'll
see if this actually produces anything
usable. So far, it's lighting money on
fire.
That's what I figured. Jess, this is not
meant to like make the LM suddenly work.
Um, the idea is if you submit, well,
first of all, it's educational, but
second of all, if you submit me a patch
that's 3,000 lines of code, I chuck this
stupid thing into Grock and 10 minutes
later it keeps all the features of your
code and spit something out that's half
the length, your patch sucked.
The problem is that his coat is golfed
as [ __ ] man.
That would be a good idea. What? More
substeps.
Yes, but I don't know enough about that
problem specifically to know whether
your base simulator is reasonable
or whether you're going to make those
like the fidelity accuracy trade-offs in
the right spot.
You know, I kind of want to just do
this.
Let's write this top of the blog post,
but then let's Yeah, let's do it this
There.
my box.
Uh
I don't see any reason it would be
slower.
have things optimized. Just
Um,
so this is a side project where I'm just
finishing this up while I wait for this
result. We're going to see if this does
anything
and then we will do something else. I'll
explain what this is if it works.
I think that's a good preamble.
Let's pull this up
and let's see what needs to be kept of
this.
15.2.
That seems weird.
I also don't know what the heck card
would have 15 gigs of VRAM.
Okay. So, we have to get We just have to
figure out what we're missing from
There.
Oh. Um,
uh, because it's not worth my time to do
something for a 10k competition,
simply enough.
I'm actually I'm very happy. If
contributors want to go ahead and give
that a crack, go ahead.
Well, convert like not that like those
competitions are not that big of a deal
is the thing.
Has better SPS. You can definitely get
better SPS than Jax. Jax is like not
even close.
like honestly I'm really not we're kind
of at a point where I don't really care
about proving the stuff anymore.
um except in so far as like delivering
kick-ass results for clients
and I'm mostly on how do we make RL good
and stable enough to get to the hard
problems in science
like we're very close
I say as I'm here writing a stupid skill
MD file but whatever we'll I'll explain
the thing that's going on on the right
hand afterwards it's very Cool. Um,
there's some very stupid things with it
that I we have to fix, but I'll explain
that whole thing. It'll be it'll be
educational as well. I don't know how
long this dumb thing will spin for.
Yeah. So, this that is about the I'll go
changes arch. I will I'll talk about
those
or at least what's trying to what's
going on with that.
Yeah, I've seen that. Um,
their stuff is a very it's kind of
different to be honest. Like some of
their stuff is good, some of their stuff
is for a very different application.
action trees still ongoing. Finn was
away for a good chunk of last week.
Um, I don't think
is that a problem, Arch? I don't think
precision of action selection is a big
problem with continuous spaces. I mean,
you could probably construct a problem
where it is, but not anything that we
deal
Interesting. There's a lot of stuff we
could do at the moment, Arch. Like, I'd
rank that pretty low in terms of stuff
that's making things not learn.
Hello. Haven't gotten a blog in a while.
You're looking at one
combination of blog and other thing.
I think we almost have everything
incorporated.
Just let's just let's leave this to the
user.
I did not switch back to GPT Arch. This
is for a side project. You're going to
see it gets ditched uh as soon as I
actually start doing things because
look, this thing's been spinning for an
hour
more actually.
Yeah, I I do not believe that uh anybody
that is like using these super slow
models um as their like primary thing
that they're doing. I don't believe
anybody in that case is doing serious
work.
Like you're just so completely out of
the loop that it's just it's nothing.
We're going to shorten this a little
bit.
Why worry about shortening it if the
content is good?
Uh, this to me should be something that
is tight.
I think that this should be tight for
the same reason that the code should be
tight.
This is not pros.
Believe me, Jess, I'm capable of writing
like a huge amount of stuff very
quickly. Um, it's often the right thing
to do. You're writing pros,
well I think this is not going to be
something we publish. I think that we
start with the small version of this and
then we see what this thing misses
right.
Hi, Finn. Yeah. So, um this is I guess
now is a reasonable time to explain
what's going on on the right hand side.
All right.
So this weekend
I wanted to do just a little bit of work
on the side and there was an idea that I
wanted to try out that like normally
would take me a week or two to
investigate properly at the very least.
Okay.
And
uh that idea goes something like this.
PO has some clipping terms on it that
are meant as an off policy correction.
They're intended to prevent you from
collapsing your policy by iterating on
very slightly stale data. However, if
you crank up the amount of sample reuse,
you count up crank up the number of
update epochs, that is, you will just
collapse the entire algorithm.
This seems like an algorithmic defect to
me. If we're going to have clipping
terms to prevent us from using data that
is too stale,
then we should be able to crank up the
number of batches as much as we want.
And when updates are too stale, the
algorithm should just be able to zero
those.
That was the idea. And this is important
because first of all, it takes a
hyperparameter that's the replay use a
replay ratio and it makes it stable. So
if you increase it, you'll never break
anything. Um it's an important
invariance where I think that not having
this could hide other numerical problems
with the algorithm. Um you know this is
sort of correlated with a lot of other
things that the algorithm does as well
and how it works.
And uh also with the introduction of
asynchronous training, we need a little
bit more control than we previously did
over data steness. And uh this is a very
good way to get that. Okay.
So pretty much what I did was this
weekend since again this was not a
project that I would normally invest
time into uh at this stage not in puffer
5 but I said okay whatever I'll just
take 20 minutes to write down a precise
set of experiments to run and I'll just
hand it to codeex and see what happens.
Okay. And I I did something like this. I
essentially said uh wrote down what I
just told you all and then I said look
uh we know that there are existing
clipping terms in several places. We
even have important sampling in our
version of puffer liib. So we should
sort of already be correcting
um for various stale updates. So start
cranking up the replay ratio and see
where stuff breaks and add some logging
in to see exactly where it is that we
are destabilizing our policy if it's in
one place or multiple places and you
know report back on results. Here's the
breakout environment. It's already very
nicely tuned. There's a sweep utility
that's very fast. Individual runs take
less than 2 seconds.
Okay. So, I put this thing together and
this thing spun for like an hour and a
half while I did other things. It was a
Saturday and uh it came back and said,
"Hey, you know, uh it looks like the
muon orthogonalization is messing you up
and also possibly the momentum." And I
go, "Oh crap. Yeah, this totally that
optimizer totally was not designed for
this setting, right? It wasn't designed
for increasingly stale updates over
time. that totally messes with momentum.
Muon makes it even worse with
orthogonalization.
So I said, "Cool. Um
here's uh here's an idea, right? Go
investigate the current clipping terms
and the important important sampling. Uh
thread that correction through the
optimizer update as well as through uh
the momentum update
and see if you can get this thing to be
stable at arbitrarily high R." So if you
go to a th00and it's not expected to
make uh to make training any better but
it should not collapse anything.
And then the thing spun and spun and it
produced a whole bunch of changes that
looked pretty reasonable. And I had it
write up a lat document. Let me see if I
can find it.
Yeah, I had it write up this whole
document and it took me like a couple
hours to go through all the math and it
completely cheated. It actually has some
stuff that's reasonable that's actually
you know pretty difficult to uh you know
it's pretty reasonable and took me a
while to see exactly how it did it and
it it was actually very good. But then
it also did some stuff that was just
completely stupid. And the biggest one
of those was essentially just threw a
big exponential decay over mini batches.
So like, yeah, obviously if you just run
it for more mini batches, it's basically
just running zero updates for no reason.
So this is why I was annoyed this
morning saying, "Yeah, good job, Open
AI. You've gotten there. These models
are definitely superhuman at lying." Um
cuz that's an error that I like
in my mind that's an error that you'd
have to be very very stupid to make
because this is not like a technical or
mathematical error. This is just like uh
you know oh let's solve the problem in a
way that obviously doesn't remotely
matter and is completely against the
point of the test. Right?
just being pushed to zero.
Um,
I don't know if that's the
orthogonalization, Finn. I think that's
just the update in general will push
logits to zero, right?
Like it'll push actions that don't seem
to be useful to zero. And the only thing
fighting against it is the entropy
bonus.
Uh this file is I think would be equally
useful for people as well. Like if you
read this and just if you refactor this
way it'll be better as well.
I think yeah I think this is good for
now.
So this is what like once we get this
it's like one screen.
So this is what we're going to do. I'm
going to take this. I'm going to post
I'm going to copy this current version
into a blog post because Whoops.
That's weird. Let me just put this into
a blog post real quick. I'm not
publishing this yet, obviously.
Why they keep changing the UI, man? It's
really annoying to me.
right, cool.
Now what we can do is we can get rid of
this because this is now in this
article.
Nice. Look at this. One screen.
I like that. that it's just one screen
of uh
of side.
I mean obviously I just mean at my
default font size it's a it's 44 lines.
I'll probably end up tweaking this, but
I figure I'll just use this on a couple
like random lowquality PRs
and uh we'll essentially just see
whether it's any good and if there's
anything that I can obviously improve
with
I think we'll just we'll see. We'll see
what it does for this and we'll see if
it figures out to run tests or not.
I think we're good with this. How the
hell is this stupid thing still
spinning?
Like, I literally don't know what it's
doing.
Okay, I guess we're going to go try uh
I guess we're going to try
No, man. It's just a very long running
stupid thing. Like if it comes up with
something, cool. If it doesn't, well, I
guess we're no worse off than before.
I I don't think that they're
intentionally making the models crap. At
least Open AAI isn't like like there's
no conspiracy or anything here.
Um,
my objections are mostly to their
grandstanding and their regulatory
capture [ __ ]
Algo stuff.
Uh, so Jess, the algo stuff is aimed at
stabilizing
very off-paul updates,
which will allow us to be more effective
with async. not necessarily to use
offpol updates, but to make sure that
they don't destabilize things. And
uh this is
this is the current
I think ready for testing like dumb
skill doc thing.
I'm going to point this at like a few
lowquality PRs when I merge it or
whatever.
I'll try it with a couple different
language models.
And I mean, I think this is mostly good
for human use.
We'll see whether it's good for LLM use.
I mean, this is right here. This is this
is the algorithm, right? It's you just
literally inline everything. You get rid
of stupid error checks. You look at like
logic level stuff um like really deeply
indented code. Typically, you look to
invert conditionals, return early, you
merge trivial checks, and then once
you've done these basics, you typically
you can co-optimize a little bit. If you
think about like, oh, well, I split this
function out that's used in two places
here and here, but if I didn't instead
split it out this other way, would it be
shorter? Try it out.
And then finally, uh, just a bunch of
syntax and style stuff at the bottoming
I'm going to paste this just to you.
We'll just send this to you.
What does it take to understand RL and
code it? It depends on what level you
mean. Like you can make a basic thing.
Um
probably
there's like maybe five papers you need
to read to implement something basic.
But the thing is RL is not one of those
fields where you implement the basic
thing and it actually works well. um
like getting our core to where it is to
where it works super well is much much
harder. Um for writing environments,
environments are actually easy like
simple environments are very easy to
write now. I would say it requires like
firstear level systems knowledge and a
little bit of RL. Uh it scales though
very high like very complex problems are
very hard to solve.
What do I use for coding? Um, not this
thing. This thing is awful. This is a a
separate experiment I have. Uh, once I
actually go start doing something real,
it'll probably be uh Brock and then I
mean myself hand coating things.
I'm trying to think what we do from
here. We have any word from the fin?
probably asleep, right? No, he was here
a while ago.
Let's see if he's awake.
Five papers. They're already in my
guide. If you just hit my articles tab
on X, there's um ultra opinionated guide
to RL that has all the resources you
need.
Some matrix inside an optimal controller
some matrix inside
Um, tuning uh a like tuning specific
params. That's more of a hyper pram
sweep thing than it is RL. We have that
as well.
Progress on net hack.
I mean, Finn has uh has bumped the score
a bit higher, but I haven't touched it
in the last few days. That's going to be
quite soon.
I'm trying to think what to do next
here. It kind of depends on whether
there's anything here or not. If there's
nothing here, then we kind of proceed as
before.
I don't want to bottleneck myself on
this though.
So, I'm thinking what we need to do to
ship um
to ship 50. It's mostly just the end of
integrations and the tests.
Mostly just the end of integrations and
the tests.
Oh, there's Finn simplifying and re
sweeping to make dev faster. Yeah,
definitely Finn, if you just shoot over
your uh I don't if you're already on 5C
as well, like just the NPR and every you
can just PR whatever you have as soon as
you're uh you're set for the evening cuz
I'm going to want to probably soonish.
I want to see if it just improves score
out of the box with any of these things,
frankly, because that would be a very
very strong validation and I can run
that pretty quickly.
Whereas just whatever this thing does on
breakout is kind of eh
48 8 2048 is good for sure and that's
going to be the one that I'm going to
use like separately. I will use 2048.
In fact, we can probably do that right
uh right after this.
Oh yeah, let me just take a quick look
actually here. While this finishes, let
me use the restroom real quick and then
if this is still running, I will I'll
take a quick look at what PRs we have.
This is just a sub. I like I don't use
this thing very much, man. This is like
this is a oneoff experiment from this
weekend.
Um
and then I just have the Gro sub for my
normal stuff.
like this here. This is not how I
actually do any of my engineering. Like
I never just let a thing spin on an
engineering problem for an hour cuz it
makes a mess of the code. The thing that
this is for, this is experimenting with
some algorithmic changes. And this is
essentially like if this works, then I
clean up the algorithm and I implement
it correctly. And like I set aside a
bunch of time to fix all the code
because like this is not going to
produce usable code, right? This might
produce a positive algorithm like
algorithmic result though and run some
decent ablations. That's the question.
Now 1.5x like faster is not this is not
remotely acceptable for this thing to
spin for an hour and a half. Like
typically when I'm making edits to stuff
with Grock, like it spins for 30 seconds
to a few minutes,
even for relatively big edits.
Uh, I'll be right back. Use the restroom
and grab a drink real quick.
Let's go check some PRs
at least. Let's just see what we have in
the uh in the pipeline.
I didn't merge this.
Oh, I did. I I pulled it on to 5C.
Yeah. Yeah, I pulled this into 5C
already.
Um
yeah, this has already gotten. We
already pulled this in
selfplay tonight or will self play be
another day?
Uh it depends, Jess. It was going to be
today if this thing worked.
Uh, I think it makes a little bit of
sense for me to take a bit longer before
I switch fully. I do need to do selfplay
stuff though. That is the currently
active thing.
Yeah, we have like
lots of AI gen crap. We do have some
nice M's.
We do have some nice M's.
I'm just seeing if I like missed
anything super major. I think it's
mostly M's. M's are very easy to pull
in.
I think that gets us up to um
Oh, this is the Anen
actually. That's nice. I I actually do
want that. Cool.
Like anything that you think you're
going to get by having the code and go,
uh, you're going to lose by having to
work across two languages.
I also, for reference, I do really like
C as a language. I think C is a very
like C is a super solid language and
there's not really stuff that I want um
from other languages that I feel like
I'm missing
honestly. Like most of the complexity is
just CUDA kernels being chunky
and
annoying when you need them to be really
fast for tiny networks.
Let me think if there's an obvious thing
for this. So,
I we should look at the current code a
little bit, I'd say.
Let's go look at our current code in
here. Whoops. Oops. Oops. Oops. Oops.
I don't know why I keep clicking that
button.
It still makes me happy seeing this.
And this is just like it's so nice to
have all the code this short.
Okay, here's train imple. So what are we
doing at the moment?
and then in here.
Do we recmp compute advantage?
It looks like at some point we lost
we lost the advantage recomputation.
It looks like
and then what is this? We scatter
priority.
Oh, value and advant update value and
advantage estimates.
How and when to update value
and advantage estimates.
Okay, we need to think about this. So
the advantage function
I'm really proud of this. It's less than
10k lines for all of Puffer.
Okay, Finn's doing well.
Just checking in with him on uh on net
hack. It looks like he's doing well.
the value function tracks the current
policy, right?
So if you optimize perfectly
the value function will learn exactly
what the previous policy did. So the
value function is also one epoch stale
right
let's go through
I think we need to look at the
importance sampling then don't we
I need to just like understand
I honestly I think I just need to
understand the important sampling
better.
I think this this chunk I understand,
but I'm using this as a preamble.
Okay.
Hey, glitzy.
Okay, so this was spurious like this was
just confusing me. It's fine. My
understanding is correct.
This is a correct.
I didn't see this in VR. There are a
couple other things.
Joseph, check my code.
Oh, okay.
He made the PR anyways, which is good.
The only thing I really care about with
uh dirty PRs like this is
is this.
I'll go.
Yeah. So, this is the only thing I care
about.
Don't Yeah, I'm not going to merge it
yet, Finn, because you have stuff in the
main net hack path. I this uh honestly
like okay I understand that during dev
there's stuff that like it's tough to
not have in puffl. Um ideally we're
going to get stuff just to beat in net
hack. We will see.
But at least you have it open so I can
look at stuff. Is it good?
to play with this. You will have to play
with this
So that'll be perfect timing.
So I think that we really we haven't
missed anything.
Um
should be fine. But anything more
technical than this is going to start
getting out of hand. So I think that I
think we're just fine here.
So,
what is the thought here?
Yeah.
Okay. This is the thing that I think I'm
still missing a little bit of
mathematical background on.
What's happening?
So, I ran an experiment over the weekend
where I thought I had gotten a very good
result. Well, when I say I ran, I kind
of just yoloed a thing with the with
Codeex over the weekend. Just I do that
sometimes cuz if it gets a positive
result, it can be very useful. If it
gets a negative result, it might have
just been dumb. Who knows? Um, but I
thought I got a very positive result. I
spent like two hours checking the math
and it completely just cheated. But
there were still some really good
findings. Um, and there were some things
that I could work with. So, we're seeing
if we get anything out of it. The goal
would be to massively stabilize OffPaul
updates, which would be very, very
helpful now that we have async. Um,
but we basically we still have to see
I think the ratio we're using is even
redundant possibly.
Check dev channel.
Hang on.
Oh, cool.
Very cool.
uh
picks it up pretty weird, but okay.
Yeah, that works.
Gardener's outside. Like I was just
like, "Oh, suddenly somebody's in my
window.
500 mil steps. No, we don't really care
about the uh the samples with it, right?
Like 500 mil if it's fast is cool.
I'm just seeing if I'm missing stuff.
So, sometimes I do this type of stuff
and it's mostly just sanity checking to
like see if I'm missing something.
It's not fast. A thousand substeps per
salsa is.
Yeah, it's a lot.
Isn't it free though?
Isn't it literally free?
Hang on. I think it's literally free.
Oh, okay.
Uh,
Now, the only thing that we Okay,
there's a lot of empirical crap we still
have to check.
GH
that crashes completely.
My read on it currently is that like
a lot of math is hard and sort of the
way that chess is hard.
But like if chess had a 20,000 page rule
book
it's it's like a I I think it's just a
very large space to search over and like
a very small number of people that can
effectively even attempt to start
searching ing over that space based on
the
knowledge prerequisite
and speak to whether the chess problem.
Well, so Jess like so everybody who is
playing chess like you can you can teach
somebody the rules very quickly and then
they can start like looking ahead at
moves and they can like run the search
process in their head manually
um given enough time. It's a really big
space so they'll be bad at pruning it
but at least they can run it a little
bit right. Um
whereas with higher math
the prerequisite to be able to even like
do anything in the search space is very
high
such that there are very few people who
can actually contribute at that level
and the search space is still very
large.
That's sort of my read on it at the
moment.
how much math
my work is not particularly math heavy.
It does come up at now and again. Um,
my work is probably like 80% engineering
heavy, 15% math or no not 15% math, 5%
math, like 15% basic science.
Actually, why is that a bad question?
Let me think. This is a bad qu This is a
bad question.
it essentially just says discard this
update
if we've already moved the policy too
much. Right.
And then yeah, so under that it would be
there's also a value clamp, right?
So under that actually PO should
literally already be stable.
This seems sketchy to me.
This actually does seem very sketchy to
me.
how you get the most out of co there's
no getting the most out of codecs.
There's no skill whatsoever involved in
using language models.
I'm I'm trying to understand like a
subtle point about the um
about the implications of important
sampling versus
po's normal clipping.
I think we just have to ablade it,
right?
But the thing I think that the key thing
was um
the policy difference either way, right?
Hang on. Because
how do we do that?
How do we do that? Um,
it's actually not difficult with our
original setup.
I definitely understand the problem way
more now, though.
Yeah, I definitely understand the
problem way more. So, here's the thing,
right? Um,
Muan is really not built for this and
actually to a lesser extent neither are
any momentum based optimizers. So the
momentum term right is going to get
updated
based on your number of updates.
Yeah. See, when the gradients get
smaller
Yeah. When the gradients get smaller,
you update.
You have this decaying
tracker.
Yeah, this is definitely wrong.
This is definitely wrong for RL.
I think this might actually be a very
good insight.
LM capability. They're useful but very
dumb.
At least in at least in many important
ways, they're still very dumb.
That's funny.
There's like one Reddit post.
Hukeman
found this actually it seems
but doesn't fix it. He found it but
didn't fix it.
That's crazy. There's literally there's
one comment from 2019.
That's actually probably why um
I wouldn't be surprised that's why we
saw RMS prop in some of the older RL
papers. They probably just tried both
optimizers without realizing
without realizing that. Can't you prompt
your way? No, you can't.
Yeah, I mean that's
in one on one side that's actually
embarrassing to have missed that for so
long.
I'm kind of embarrassed to have not
thought about that.
Then again, apparently neither did
anybody else. But
[ __ ]
Well, we got to fix that.
That's like a very clear-cut bug.
So,
regardless of whether this does
anything,
I now at least know the precise thing to
fix.
That's crazy.
Oh, plasticity research in RL. Um, I
don't maybe. Let me think. I don't think
so.
I also kind of want to look into the max
ant formulation though. That's super
different.
He has half of the problem but not the
other half.
Maxon has some janky [ __ ]
Let's see. Is there a simple form of Max
Ant that isn't tied to the whole mess of
SACE?
Uh,
I
don't trust this just based on
authorship.
Thank you for the prime bet. Ignore your
ad free viewing.
Wait, is that actually Alex?
Oh, I don't feel bad about this at all.
If this is Alex, um, this is like one of
the actually only good people in the
field.
Okay, I don't feel bad about this
anymore. Like, Alex,
Alex is one of the only people that I
still have like a lot of respect for in
this field. It's not Livian, it's Ben.
Like, some of the other papers kind of
don't work too well.
Uh, yeah, I Sergey just has a ton of
students.
I don't know anything about him
personally. He seems cool though.
Glitzy, is there a um is there a simple
like is there a simplest possible max
ant formulation?
Yeah, he's a sample factory author
convert.
He was the first to get RL up to like
100k SPS single machine.
Different playing. Move on. Hang on. Let
me let me check Glitzy's link. Oh, this
thing is done. Look, it worked for three
hours.
Let me just grab Glitzy's link before I
lose it.
Thank you.
Oh,
wait. Is this what caution is?
This thing is weird.
I don't understand what this is. Oh, not
your link. I'm sorry. This is the wrong
person.
Let me go take a look at uh what we
have.
It does seem weird glitches. Like it
does seem weird.
types.
Yeah, caution hasn't done anything. I'll
take a quick look at it. Um, it seems
kind of weird though to me. Like
I remember playing with this in heavy
ball and it didn't do anything.
Protein sweet bells.
Yep. They're not mega broken.
They're actually they work very well.
I do have a pretty clear-cut idea now of
what the thing is uh how the thing is
wrong.
10 mms.
That'll be nice.
I definitely need to fix this now. This
is a very clear bug thing. Bad problem.
Actually, Schulman missed this.
That's crazy.
let me think probably you both apply and
update the momentum
in proportion to the
the clip frack All right.
Completely ignoring all of the important
sampling crap.
This makes sense.
Okay. Massive respect to um to Alex
here.
It's funny because like he does a lot of
really good work but at least from
sample factory he has a very very
different approach to implementations.
Yeah, I think you want you want
momentum, man. You just you want to fix
you want to keep momentum. I think.
But then you want to apply it in
proportion to the clip frack.
That would be my guess.
Oh yeah, that caution thing is total
[ __ ] as well. Like um just think of
that with uh with mini batch size one.
You're instantly screwed. So
let's not do that.
is outside of you and Alex.
Well, I mean, look at the original
paper. The original paper uses Adam.
No momentum correction.
RMS prop.
Oh,
the impala paper. Got it.
Or wait, no, momentum is zero. Is this
normally zero?
Did the Impala paper get it?
Nope. That's the default.
Okay. So, the I think the Impala Paper
got lucky basically.
If there's no mention of this in the
Impala paper.
Yeah, there's no mention of this.
Okay, so this is what happened, guys.
The Impala paper, they got lucky with
RMS prop.
They probably just tried both and saw
that RMS prop worked better and just
took it as an empirical choice.
cuz this thing goes way more off policy.
So yeah,
I wonder if this is like giga massively
broken or like only slightly broken.
It's probably like slightly broken in
normal use, but then it's like strictly
the cause of
um degenerate behavior with a ton of
samples.
He's not. But Alex is not um
not on this, right?
No, Alex not on this.
He was a PhD student. This is from
Yeah, this is Google. He was a PhD
student at the time.
I'm pretty sure
This thing is crap.
This
might be a bet.
Not this.
problem causes in practice.
Um, you basically just get screwed by
high sample reuse.
It's a pretty clear [ __ ] up though in
the algorithm.
It's an independent discovery,
though I think the original is more
impressive because it wasn't AI
assisted.
Um,
it was both though. like the um
it was like GPT didn't just find the
whole thing either
It's not the same thing bet because you
can't just let a hammer go on its own
and have it build a albeit very shitty
house.
So the contribution is much more
obvious.
But the thing is, you're off policy
before like you're off policy after the
first mini batch, not after the first
epoch.
It's much worse.
You see?
I think that's it.
This is
I think that's basically it. This is a
good find.
So to sort of recap um the procedure
here right was I like to sort of
summarize what's happened over the last
24 hours yesterday I wanted to look into
the source of collapse at very high
sample reuse in PO because looking at
the base algorithm actually if you think
about it it shouldn't collapse apps.
Um,
I went I like gave a few things to
codeex for that to add some logging and
instrumentation to see where the bad
update happens at high sample reuse.
Eventually, this got to the optimizer
momentum
and then the orthogonalization.
Uh, I was considering trying to thread
important sampling in, but I think that
that was much too complicated.
So, I gave it that. It came up with a
dumb reward hack that was stupid, that I
thought worked, but was dumb. Then it
tried to more correctly thread an
important sampling, which I thought
would be a reasonable idea. But on
reflection, given that we weren't really
using that correctly in the first place,
I think there's a much simpler version
of this that's very close to PO and
looks a lot more like our exact
algorithm we're using now with one small
optimizer correction. Um, so I think
that we'll test that next
and we will go from there.
Uh, I actually think the entropy bonus
will be fine because the whole update is
already going to get scaled by this
fraction,
like this clip fraction. So, I think
we're fine.
I think we're fine.
The momentum update might need to be
handled slightly differently
because I believe we orthogonalize
we only orthogonalize the gradient,
right? I I don't know actually the order
of operations there. It act it matters
quite a bit. We'll figure that out. No
big deal though. We'll figure that
and uh we will
probably have some results tomorrow.
This is actually very good because in my
mind like
RRL is getting very very good and the
thing in my mind that's holding us back
the most like yes there are some very
specific capabilities that I would like
to have consistently work but um I think
that the biggest thing overall frankly
is just a general feeling of RL still
having a little bit of jank left around
hyperparameters and setup up
and this could very well be one of the
major major sources. I mean clipping is
like a lot of the different
hyperparameters
factor into clipping.
So I think that this is going to be
pretty promising. I'll be back probably
streaming this tomorrow.
And uh that's basically what we're
doing. Let's see. I'll be back streaming
this tomorrow. I'm going to call it a
day here. We'll see what happens. And uh
yeah, thank you all for tuning in. Star
of the Puffer on GitHub. If you're new
around here, it helps us out a lot. Join
us on Discord to get involved with dev
and follow on X for more RL content.